in the cold of winter solidarity among
striking staff more than 20 000
ambulance workers are taking industrial
action in England and Wales in a dispute
officially about pay but really so much
more than just that
the frustrations are the long long
handovers at the hospitals which are
delaying our ability to turn out and
deliver care to our patients the
pressure that that's putting upon our
staff we all join to look after folk and
we're not we're waiting we're waiting to
look after folk we're losing valuable
staff because they're the pressures
they're feeling
we can't deliver the care that we want
to deliver as paramedics
[Music]
during this war
urgency crew
people are being told to only call for
an ambulance if it is life-threatening
or a very serious situation unlike the
Royal College of Nursing who agreed a
national minimum service level the
ambulance unions have refused to do that
insisted on local Arrangements obviously
that meets contingency planning much
more difficult in terms of safeguarding
patient safety
the ambulance service here in Yorkshire
is still providing some cover and we saw
people on the picket line rushing off to
respond to emergencies
this crisis comes after talks between
the government and unions broke down
earlier this week but staff say it
reflects a deeper crisis within
Britain's NHS
and this has fast become Prime Minister
Rishi sunak's winter of discontent with
nurses and other public sector workers
also walking out
but the truth is Mr Speaker I'm proud to
come from an NHS family and that's why
I'm passionately committed to protecting
it with more funding more doctors and
nurses and a clear plan to cut the
waiting list Donna has been a nurse for
37 years she's also a labor counselor
and we've always advocated for our
patients which always made made taking
action like this
um quite difficult and quite a moral
dilemma as much as anything however I
think that now because of the Staffing
levels because of the safe looking
safety of patients we need to be able to
advocate for our patients and this is
the only way that we can see to do it
many staff say this crisis isn't just
down to Winter pressures but years of
under investment which is denied by the
government
here they're concerned about the impact
a strike has on their patients but say
they need to safeguard the future of the
service they set out to provide Emma
Hayward Al Jazeera Sheffield in northern
England